oh hello I'm back in Los Angeles yeah
getting ready to go up to Boston
tomorrow for the start of our nofilter
tour shows yeah Boston Austin do you see
San Francisco and Los Angeles make sure
you grab your tickets if you haven't
already okay back on the train of
thought I actually have a day kind of
off what I feel weird I feel weird
I was talking to Mary before and she
mentioned that anytime she needs get
inspired creatively for something she
goes to Michaels which is a big craft
store so I decided today I'm gonna go to
Michaels cuz I don't have anything to do
and be sitting alone with my thoughts is
never good okay we're here at one thing
I sincerely hope they have is the
bathroom because I only saw the outside
of the store and I'm too excited and I'm
gonna pee and someone's when I get
really excited I have to urinate what a
fun little thing got invented about my
body
[Music]
I'm really overwhelmed right now
a lot of things have happened I guess
okay I got very carried away there was
so much stuff
I've favorite place
and his name is Michaels again did you
wanna explain what's happening right now
we're more Michaels looking back I'm
going back to Michaels yeah I was just
there - oh those are Devils
why are we going back I don't want to
bring you don't even know what do I not
know how beautiful it really is I know
mmm feel better find out are you excited
that seems flustered
if accepted buying a dog and Dorothy Oh
[Music]
looking glamorous just looking our best
no spilling uh you'd think that we'd be
used to traveling over some reason oh
you're trying on our cobbler
oh maybe get your head in there if you
just show this you're almost like dick
tips yeah I don't have my head out I
just have my head nestled gently in this
pencil cave hey I just yeah we're
outside the Wilbur the night before the
show probably short we're just waiting
to see if our thing comes up up there Oh
your example we've been waiting so long
for this are embarrassing do you think
those yeah dammit dammit damn band
we're probably after noir McDonald yeah
you're buildin no Phil come on Oh like
listening oh so close so close ooh
memory women with Apple what your
headshots look great names what are you
doing get out of here damn it who's that
we'll give it five more oh that's cool
really that's really cool I like that
you guys all turned around to
acknowledge the camera thank the 50
shades experts oh okay two more angry
parkouring eh cooler oh she got me yeah
you're strong you pick me with one hand
hit it
still winning hey who sits next one it's
gotta be no but we've already seen this
I don't think we're up on it
I don't think we're on it right now well
should we are not a good morning Boston
out of you Oh memory and our walking
this morning and look can you see it did
it go that passed god dammit god dammit
we finally saw no Phil Vischer on the
sign above the theater but oh god damnit
also good morning Mary hi you look great
look now it's back all the time that's
crazy
yeah hello backstage signing coasters
setting up pair of writing bits mark
ulcers listening to Ke$ha Pandora
station named Hannah or doing other
things getting ready handbag um like a
dead computer charger it's a morning
yeah this is a weird thing with the
straw like that I'm friend of my mouth
funny I don't know I'm not wait what
were you doing you were dancing thinking
that you're getting filmed no it's not
only about you
well then what do secondly oh yeah look
in this video I got obsessed they're
being so infatuated
this is my morning breakfast yeah we're
going to DC and I need to edit the
videos I don't know
this is on interesting for the past
[Music]
you